when these companies announced layoffs  their stock price goes up and you can  see clearly that many of these companies  can do more with fewer workers the stock  market and how families are doing have  essentially no relationship anymore yeah  and that's a big danger now you know one  of the things I remember so clearly from  my tenure in the White House during the  last economic crisis was you know  companies innovated and they figured out  how to do more with fewer people the  estimates I've seen say that 42 percent  of the jobs are gone for good which  makes sense any we've got to retool here  we need we need a new model within the  framework of our democracy and our  economic system we need a brand new  model that enhances opportunity for the  broadest number of people